uh the covet 19 and of course
the summit the eu india summit
what covet 19 is concerned i
updated leaders on the good progress
we have with our vaccination campaign
we have now delivered over 200 million
doses
to the european people so we are on
track
to achieve our objective of enough doses
being delivered in july
to vaccinate 70 percent of the european
adult population
of course delivering vaccine doses is
good
but vaccination is even better so
the numbers here are close to 160
million europeans
now have already received a first shot
of the vaccine
that's over 25 percent of the eu
population
this is good news and we will continue
like this a topic that was important is
of course that everybody's thinking
about the summer season
and i understand how important that is
it is important for people to plan ahead
the holidays it is so
important for workers in tourism
hospitality
or in the transport sector who hope to
be once again
in employment and for businesses of
course in those sectors
who are expecting to start their
recovery recovery
to achieve this vaccination is indeed
the key parameter but we must also
enable travel
within and to the european union so i
updated yesterday the leaders on the
progress
in this area i'm glad to report
that the legal and the technical work on
the eu
travel certificate the vaccination
certificate
is on track for the system to be
operational
in june there are two different
approaches that are important there one
is the political front
here thanks to the excellent job done by
the portuguese presidency in the council
as well as the parliament's speed in
reaching a position
we can realistically aim to have a
political agreement by the end of this
month
and this would allow for the system to
be rolled out and people to carry with
them
unfalsifiable proof
that they have been vaccinating or they
have a negative
mutually recognized test or they have
overcome
covet and thus antibodies
there was another point i could report
on
yesterday because of course this is one
track now to overcome the pandemic here
through the vaccination campaign but of
course we must not let our guard down
and we must prepare for the future
and therefore i was glad that i could
announce that
we now concluded the negotiations with
biontech pfizer
for a new contract a new contract
looking
forward to the years 22 and 23.
the new contract secures 1.8 billion
doses of vaccines mainly because there
are three more
topics that are clear for us we have to
cover
with potential vaccines the one the
first
topic is sooner or later children and
teenager
will be vaccinated for that we have to
prepare
second there is the question of how long
does the immunity last
with the first two shots of vaccination
so when is it necessary after
a certain amount of time to give a boost
for the vaccination for the whole
european population again
and of course the big and important
topic
of escape variants or sometimes they're
being called variants of concern
and these two these three topics
are for us important to be covered to be
prepared for
therefore now this big follow-up
contract with biotech pfizer
but of course we will also explore other
contracts for example
based on other technologies like the
protein based
technologies the key point is to keep
our options
open and we have seen how crucial it is
for us to have a broad
portfolio of vaccines to be prepared
for unexpected issues finally of course
we have discussed the
role of the european union in the global
vaccination
effort and when it comes to the proposal
of a temporary trips waiver
for vaccine intellectual property rights
as i've said before i think it
is very important we should
be we should be open to this discussion
we should also for example have a close
look
at the role of licensing it is an
important
these are important topics to discuss
but we should be aware of the fact that
these are topics for the long term
it's not a topic for the short term or
the median term
and we should therefore not lose sight
of the main
urgencies now which is ramping up indeed
the vaccine production as quickly as
possible
and ensuring that they are fairly and
evenly distributed
so there are three topics that should be
tackled with a discussion about
trips waiver or licensing and this is
first of all export
the european union is the pharmacy of
the world and
open to the world up to today in the
european union
400 million doses of vaccines have been
produced
and 50 percent of them 200 million doses
have been exported
to 90 different countries in the world
so we invite
others to do the same this is the best
way
right now in the short term to approach
the bottlenecks and the lack of vaccines
worldwide
the second point indeed is that we have
to support covax we have massively
financed covax
as well as sharing our vaccines both via
corvex
and bilaterally with our neighborhood
some member states have already shared
like romania france and austria
but also committed to do so like spain
like portugal
like sweden and i know that poland is
going to follow
and the third topic is indeed
the investment in global manufacturing
we have invested a lot with the advanced
purchase agreements
in the manufacturing or scaling up of
the manufacturing
right now as we see it but there needs
to be
more investment in global manufacturing
capacity
for example the commission in
partnership with germany is already
helping
to develop local pharmaceutical
manufacturing
capacity in the southern part of
africa and we are also supporting the
development of the
astitu pasteur in dakar and senegal
together with the
european investment bank france germany
and belgium
so these are just examples how to
approach that topic
and last but not least the european
commission is working
on a flagship team europe initiative
with our african partners to very
concretely build up capacity
in africa this topic was
also and this is the bridge the topic of
course that has been
discussed with prime minister modi
indeed it was for us a very
important historical moment first of all
to make sure that
the european union stands firmly at the
side of
india in this most challenging time
and we assured the prime minister of our
solidarity
and the support with all what is needed
at the moment being from
ex-oxygen generators to medicines
and ventilators 17 eu member states
have supported with over 100 million
euros of supply
that has been brought to india and is
being brought in the next days
through the eu civil protection
mechanism and further assistance
will follow it was a
remarkable summit because
it widened the scope and the view
on the untapped potential in the
relationship of the european union
and india and i really want to thank you
antonio
that you seized your presidency to
organize this
summit this is outstanding this is
historical
and it was impressive to see
around the table of the 27 to have this
extraordinary summit it is a landmark
moment and indeed
we have agreed that we will resume the
negotiations
on a free trade agreement if you just
keep in mind
that free trade agreement negotiations
started in 2007
have been stopped in 2013
and nothing happened in between and now
they are being resumed that shows
the importance of this summit
we will also launch negotiations on
investment
production protection and of
negotiations on the important topic of
geographical
indications
there were other discussions on other
topics
like cooperation on the world trade
organization reform
regulatory cooperation and resilient
value chains
we also discussed the topic of climate
change
india is the fourth biggest emitter of
greenhouse gases in the world
and it is impressive to see
how india is stepping forward now in
this topic
too we discuss the
importance of committing to climate
neutrality
and complete phase out from fossil fuels
for example in view of the crucial
un cop 26 6 so to have a very ambitious
goal
because the experience with india in the
past showed that once
india has set itself a goal it delivers
india is delivering on the goal it has
set them itself
so it is important that ambitious goals
are being
uh taken for the cop26
and last but not least our partnership
on connectivity
it is the second only of such a
connectivity partnership
after japan it will bring our two
regions closer
in mobility and transport but of course
also
in the digital field india is a
powerhouse of digitization
so this shows the width and these were
only a few examples
of the cooperation with india thanks
again to antonio costa for having
convened this summit
thank you very much
[Music]